okay today I'm going to present to you
possibly the most audacious lie of the
Donald Trump presidency and you might
hear that and say hold a hold on a
second David that sounds very hyperbolic
I know that with a guy who lies this
much how can i really say this one lie
is the most daring and fearless and
presumptive well it is Donald Trump gave
this gong show press conference in the
Rose Garden on Friday and yesterday I
played a three-minute clip of him not
answering a very straightforward
question about Mexico paying for the
us-mexico border wall when he was
confronted by CNN reporter Caitlin
Collins I've now had more of an
opportunity to review the full insanity
of this press conference and one of the
other claims that Donald Trump made
during the speech is that some other
former presidents presidents plural
you'll note told Trump that they wish
they had built the border wall when they
were presidents and that they support
Trump doing it okay take a look at this
moment in Donald Trump's press
conference but I think we're probably
talking about steel because I really
feel the other side feels better about
it and I can understand what they're
saying it is more expensive we mentioned
the price that we want five point six
billion dollars very strongly because
numbers are thrown around one point six
two point one two point five this is
national security we're talking about
we're not talking about games we're
talking about national security they
should have been done by all of the
presidents that preceded me and they all
know it some of them have told me that
we should have done it so we're not
playing games we have to do it so if
this is not true it's an extraordinarily
audacious thing to say because these are
former presidents if they have
spokespeople they have public personas
what they say is of consequence and if
they don't support the wall if they
didn't tell Donald Trump that he should
do it or that they wish they had done it
that's a pretty big deal if indeed
former presidents did support Trump
policy that actually would also be
important right that could change public
opinion if it were true that Obama and
George W Bush regretted not building a
wall and support Trump doing it that
actually could conceivably change public
opinion so this is a big deal it happens
not to be true all four former living
living former presidents I guess it's
the right way to say it have said it
definitely wasn't them who told Trump
that they support his us-mexico border
wall we heard from Bill Clinton's
spokesman who immediately said this
isn't true
Clinton hasn't spoken to Trump since the
inauguration we saw video of Clinton and
Trump at George HW Bush's funeral they
didn't say a word to each other when
Donald Trump arrived george w bush's
spokesman said trump has never ever ever
talked about the border wall with george
w bush so it certainly wasn't him that
leaves to Barack Obama's spokesman
didn't even comment specifically instead
just saying President Obama is on the
record very clearly as saying that walls
won't solve the problems that we have
today and then lastly you have Jimmy
Carter who personally put out a
statement saying he's not spoken to
Trump about the wall and he opposes the
wall so this is a bold-faced lie and
asked for comment of Donald Trump's
acting chief of staff Mick Mulvaney said
quote I have no idea where Trump's why
Trump said this he hasn't spoken to
Donald Trump about it at all when I read
this I suspected that somewhere you
would start to see people saying well it
must have been George HW Bush who passed
away recently and it was him who
supported the wall but now we can't ask
him because he's dead first of all yeah
right secondly Trump hadn't spoken to
George HW Bush about this we know that
and thirdly that would still only be one
president and Donald Trump said that
presidents plural told him that they
support building this wall so the lies
are becoming more erratic the lies are
becoming more desperate and as I
mentioned before audacious is the word
that I that I used I wonder if it was a
world leader but not a former American
who told Trump to build the wall might
it have been a leader from I don't know
another country who likes the idea of
Trump building a border wall to inflame
tensions and divide people and Trump got
confused and said could have sworn it
was an American president who told me to
do that maybe just an idea I don't know
there's anything to that but the
pathology of Donald Trump's lies should
be apparent to everybody at this point
he is as disconnected from reality as
anyone with a serious case of
narcissistic personality disorder is he
will say whatever pops into his head pat
if he thinks it might reinforce that
strong alpha male negotiator that
persona and just imagine being 72 years
old you've lived the majority of your
life everything you know everything
you've done everything you believe in to
the to the extent that Trump has beliefs
gets you to this point of being
President of the United States and you
choose to put your eggs in the basket of
building a dumb wall and you find
yourself lying in this obvious and
demonstrable manner there's something
sad about it beyond being
extraordinarily dangerous yeah he lies
for the sake of lying even when it
doesn't get him anywhere and he lies
disregarding how falsifiable the lie is
like you only have to interview four or
five people in this case it reminded me
of when he said that after spoke
speaking to my generals I've decided to
institute a transgender military ban at
least in that instance though you could
like you know that wasn't Jim mattis or
John Kelly necessarily because you can
interview those people but there are so
many generals in the United States that
may be on the off-chance one of them or
two of them said that we have to ban
trans military members that would at
least make sense this lie I think is a
lot more egregious than that yeah you
can't actually go and talk to every
military person who might have said that
banning transer vus members is a good
idea there's four former presidents and
them supporting building this
harebrained wall would be a big deal so
obviously that's going to be fact-check
does it make any difference with his
followers I don't think it does I think
at this point they are so gone they are
so cognitively dissonant that they would
rationalize this away any number of
different ways that I can imagine none
of which I will even present to you to
avoid floating ideas to anybody that
might use them truly disgusting
I would argue this is the most audacious
slide Trump is told so far if you
disagree with me and think that there's
been a more desperate erratic or
audacious lie that he's told let me know
i'm on instagram at david pakman I hope
you're following me there and the show
is on instagram at david pakman show
after the break
part two of my interview with Dilbert
creator Scott Adams